In today's world, communication is all
about juggling multiple priorities. With
focus and intention, you can be
successful.
My name is Matt Abrahams, and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business. Welcome to
Think Fast, Talk Smart, the podcast.
Today, I am very excited to chat with my
colleague and friend Farnaz Khadem.
Farnaz is the Vice President of
University Communications at Stanford,
where she oversees the institution's
global media relations, digital
strategy, and internal communications.
Prior to Stanford, Farnaz served as the
Vice President of Communication at
Caltech. Her background includes public
service with the US Department of State
as a foreign service officer. Well,
welcome, Farnaz. Thanks for being here.
I look forward to continuing our coffee
chats so everybody can hear.
>> Yeah, thanks for having me, Matt. I'm
really actually happy to be here. You
and I've been talking for a long time
about this and having some great
conversations, and it's nice to bring it
to this forum.
>> Excellent. I agree. Shall we get
started?
>> Absolutely.
>> So, to begin, your team is involved in
many types of communication. Do you have
some overarching principle that
guides how you see effective
communication?
>> First, let me tell you that um as a
communicator, I like to think in threes.
Like, I feel like that's the way to do
it. You think in threes, you talk in
threes, you remember it, other people
remember it.
>> Excellent. Give me the three things.
>> Yeah. So, I'll tell you the three
things.
First is just know your goal, right?
Like, I think in the end, communication
is about what is it you're trying to get
across. And if you don't know what that
goal is as an individual or an
organization, you're just you're not
you're not going to be able to do
anything.
Second is know your audience. Like,
that's the other thing that people don't
always think about is you got to really
be thinking about who you're talking to.
And the third is know your data. Like, I
think we're going to probably talk a lot
about listening today. So much of
communications is about listening and
not talking, and data's the way you
listen. I mean, when you're working in
an organization like this,
you are constantly having to go back and
see what worked and what didn't. So, if
you don't know your data, you don't know
your audience, you don't know your goal.
So, it's all kind of a circle. So, those
are really our overarching principles
when we think about this.
>> Absolutely. Have to have a clear goal.
We talk a lot about goals.
Uh the the understanding your audience.
I want to talk about audiences cuz you
have many that you have to serve. And
then this notion of reflecting using
data to understand what works what
doesn't work. How do we craft that
message? Really important. A lot of
people just see the goal of
communication is getting information
out. But, it's really how does it land?
And you captured that in those three.
You [snorts] also have to traverse a
wide variety of channels, right? You
mentioned social, there's written,
magazines, newspapers.
How do you How do you think that
landscape is changing? And And how do
you approach Are there certain messages
that are better for certain channels?
That seems to be another big variable
you have to deal with.
>> Yeah. It's
It's such a good question, and it is
such a conundrum right now, right?
Because
the exponential increase of channels is
phenomenal. The noise out there, the
cacophony, right? People are overwhelmed
with information. And so, most things
don't even get through because there's
just too much out there. So, I think
part of the testing is exactly that. You
look at back to the audiences, right? We
know that some audiences uh prefer
things in short bursts. They want They
like video. They prefer Instagram.
Shorter the better. We look a lot at
like national polls, too, or
international polls. Like Pew says that
half of people right now get their news
from social media. I mean, that's
phenomenal. So, if that's a place where
we need to push out more news, we try to
do that that way.
Long-form still has a place, right?
Long-form writing, stories, they're
still really important.
But, people aren't going to read 2,000
word stories anymore. They're just very
rarely are they going to do that. So,
one of the things we do as a team is we
sit down and let's say we have a story
and we we actually go through that exact
process. We say, "Okay, like is this
better as
maybe a short piece
in writing maybe with an accompanying
video, and maybe even with a media
pitch." Like we have media relations. We
have really strong people who talk to
journalists. And
sometimes people don't need to hear
directly from us. We're actually better
off sharing it with the media who will
then share it with the public. And so we
we go through that on almost every
story.
>> I think that's a big lesson for people
to take away is that it's not just the
information, but you really have to
think about the channel and maybe it's a
multi-channel approach
for the story. And sometimes it might be
not your organization, but helping other
organizations amplify and send that out.
That's that's useful for people to think
about. One of the other things I'm super
impressed with that I think others who
aren't in a university setting who have
some comms responsibility is you'll pull
people together from different areas who
all do communication work and have them
share best practices, have them learn
from each other, really empowering and
enabling them not just through the
people process and and infrastructure
that you talked about, but by actually
having them engage with each other uh to
to feel supported cuz it can be lonely
if you're a single comms person sitting
out there, you know, in some
corporation, uh but being connected can
be really helpful.
>> We have so many great people doing
communications for organizations around
the university, but a lot of them are
one person shops. And so they're to your
point lonely, they may not have as much
knowledge about what's happening.
They don't have a a ecosystem. They
don't have that connection, that
connective tissue. And so we thought
mentorship is another great way to do
that. And it's been it was really
wonderful to see what a difference that
made in exactly for the reasons you
said.
>> So, related to mentorship, I want to
talk tangentially about a lot of what
your team does is equip people to
communicate who aren't naturally
communicators. I'm thinking of academics
or staff people working in a lab.
Do you have best practices that you've
observed either in the work you've done
or your people have done to help
somebody who might not be experienced as
a communicator, who for whatever reason
is in a position to communicate? Maybe
they've just discovered something new or
they've got some expertise that that's
being pulled to the fore.
How do you help people be better
communicators as a coach, as a guide?
>> This is one of my favorite things to do
in communications. And I've been doing
this work off and on for
decades. And one of the
best things you can do is help people
because even just a few tips takes
people such a long way.
One of the misconceptions that I have to
tell you about communications is we all
think everybody can do it. We all went
to school, we can all write, we can all
read, we can all speak, and therefore we
think communications means just that.
And communications in if you do it well
is an art. And not everybody to your
point can do that, right? And so
we we actually do we offer that kind of
training to faculty, to staff, to
others. And it's as simple as kind of
I mentioned I started out talking about
the rule of three, right? You have three
things that you want to communicate and
think about. And you just tell people
even something like that, come up with
your top three things that you want to
say.
And that's life-changing for them. They
think about that, they process, and then
they are able to more clearly
communicate their thoughts.
We can help people on camera, right? We
can put them in front of a
a video camera and then help them see
how they come across when they're
communicating. We talk to them about
their work and kind of walk them through
how to explain that in a way that is
understandable because a lot of people
are very good at being able to explain
their work in the way that they
understand it, but not necessarily in
the way that other people will
understand it.
>> Right.
>> There's a lot of things that we can do
along those lines that we really
actually enjoy doing. We think it's a
big part of our job.
>> I love that you gave three examples.
And, you know, people might not know
this, but one of the reasons that
the the leadership at the business
school, but also you in your position
were supportive of this podcast as it
started is it gave an opportunity for
faculty to practice, to get out there,
to be sharing their information because
part of it, as you said when you talked
about recording people, it's one thing
to understand how to do it. It's one
thing to know your message. It's another
thing to get the reps in doing it. And
so, I think it's great that you help
people in all those ways.
>> Exactly.
>> Uh in your various roles that you've
held, especially here, you've had to
deal with public crises.
Uh what advice do you have for our
listeners who have to deal with
challenges, perhaps not on the scale
that you have had to?
>> So, it's such an interesting question,
Matt. I don't know if I would have
started out my career or even told you a
decade ago that crisis would be one of
the things I would do most and I would
spend so much time on.
>> Right.
>> Or that I would enjoy, because I don't
think anybody can say they enjoy a
crisis. But in some ways, it's one of
the most interesting parts of doing
communications for an organization,
yeah. So, one of the things I've I've
really loved doing the last few years in
particular is going out and teaching
about how to do crisis. And so, maybe
some of what I'll share is a little bit
of what I say in these courses or talks
that I give.
Um
You know, Benjamin Franklin said, "By
failing to prepare, you prepare to
fail."
>> Yes.
>> If no one ever takes away anything else
having to do with communications, I hope
they remember that. The The most
important thing to do in a crisis is
just to have prepared in advance. So,
what does that mean?
That means, let's say you're working in
a job like mine in an organization or
any
communications job.
Think about what are your top things
that could go wrong.
In your particular job, in your
particular organization,
what are the top five scenarios of what
kind of crisis you can have? And they're
different, right? What could happen at a
university could be very different than
in a business or even in someone's
personal life. What are the things that
could happen?
And then you sort of try to plan around
those. Do you have the right
tools?
If you're in an organization, do you
have the right people? Do you know who's
supposed to do what? Do you know roles
and responsibilities? And so, that whole
process of actually thinking through
what could go wrong and putting in place
the the tools and resources you need to
address it is bar none the most
important thing you can do.
>> Excellent. So, beyond preparation, what
what are some things you advise? Let's
say a crisis does erupt and you have to
now communicate internally, externally.
What what what do you teach on how to
handle that step in the process?
>> I mean, I think there's a lot of
different things you have to think about
at that point of what what do you do? I
think one is that um
it it really ultimately when you're in a
crisis, truth and transparency are
paramount. People
want to know what is actually happening.
And if what is happening is you don't
know what is happening, you have to tell
people you don't know what is happening.
So,
don't don't assume you have to know
everything before you communicate. You
just have to communicate and tell people
what you know. Be truthful, be
transparent.
Second is in today's world with how fast
things are moving and as we talked about
the multiple channels and for example,
how quickly thing information moves on
social,
you have to do it early and often. So, I
think the days where you could say
something you could wait an hour or two
to communicate something or day or two
in a
uh crisis are long gone.
And then you have to do it regularly
over and over and over again. Again,
even if you don't know what is
happening. Those are like two of the
main things that I talk about when I
talk about uh how to how to communicate
in a crisis.
The thing I always end with to tell
people is
forgive yourself. Because here's what's
going to happen in a crisis. It is going
to be the fog of war. No matter how much
you have practiced, no matter how much
you have prepared, it's not going to go
as you think it will. The preparation
will help you, obviously, because then
you are better able to manage those
curveballs. You're not spending time on
the basics. You're spending time on
trying to manage how things are going.
But in the end, it's not going to go
exactly as you anticipate. Things are
going to go wrong.
And a lot of people beat themselves up
for that. And I think that's the one
thing is forgive yourself, go back, do
that learning, incorporate those
learnings for the next time, and just
know that's the way a crisis works.
>> I love the idea that you're doing
reflection, a postmortem, to learn.
Giving yourself grace to understand that
it's not going to go perfectly, and
there might be things that go wrong, but
we can learn from it. And yet again, you
you you didn't disappoint. Three T's:
truth, [snorts] transparency, and I'm
going to add timeliness.
>> Timeliness. Absolutely.
>> I'd like to get your insight into what
makes for a good story. Now, I know it
depends on the audience, but are there
certain elements that you you like to
see in stories? Is there, for example,
it has to have some emotional appeal, or
there has to be something vivid?
For you, [snorts] what makes for a good
story?
>> So, I love that question because there's
so much focus right now in the age of AI
on storytelling, right? So, you're
seeing articles and headlines all the
time about what is good storytelling,
what does what is the room for
storytelling in the world of artificial
intelligence, and so forth. I mean,
there are many elements, I think, to
telling a good story.
For me, personally, I think the single
most important thing is does it create a
connection?
And ultimately, a connection is usually
about something personal. You can be a
great speaker.
When I think about TED Talks, right?
What are the ones that really resonate?
It's when somebody gets up and they are
vulnerable and they share something
about themselves and their background
and who they are and all of a sudden
that connection is made, human to human.
And that is the essence of a great
story. And I think all the other things
are really important. But Matt, I got to
tell you for me and I see it in my own
personal life, right? Anytime I'm
talking to someone whether it's
one-on-one or I'm giving a talk or I'm
somewhere else, when I share something
about my background, how something in my
life taught me
a lesson that brought me to where I am,
I instantly notice a change. And so I
think that connection and that personal
nature is absolutely core.
>> As somebody who has interacted with you
and heard the stories you tell, you
you're very good at connecting and you
you have several techniques to do it.
You like to use analogies, you like to
use descriptive language and there are a
lot of tools that can enable that
connection, but I agree. It it boils
down to connection. And you alluded to
AI. So I'd love to ask the the AI
question.
AI is impacting communication all over
the place. As somebody who runs a
communication organization,
what is your approach to using AI to
help and also being concerned about some
of the problems that come with people
who use AI in terms of hallucinations
and other things?
>> So we spend a lot of time talking about
AI.
>> Yes.
>> I I believe very strongly in moderation
in all things and that carries over for
me into the workplace and AI is a really
good example of this. So the way we're
really approaching it in a much more
moderated and methodical fashion,
every person in the University
Communications team at Stanford has to
have an AI goal.
>> Okay.
>> Right? That was something that I said at
the beginning of this year. But what
that means is very different from person
to person and from team to team. For
some people, that may be my goal is I'm
going to take a class and try to
understand better how to write prompts.
For someone else, it might be more of an
incorporation
into their daily work.
And I largely let the team know. I said,
"I want you to do this for you, not so
much even for me, for the institution. I
think that having familiarity with these
tools is going to be so important for
the next generation of people in
communications. And so,
I think it's incumbent on me to help
them learn how to use it."
And there are some really great things
that we can and are using AI for. So, I
think one of the certainly can make a
lot of processes easier, whether it be
in the writing or editing phase or so
forth, we can use it. And we're thinking
about more how to use it for targeting
particular audiences, cuz I think AI can
do a lot to help us find the right
audiences for our messages.
But then to the flip side of what you
asked about, there are a lot of
problems, too, that can come with that
if people rush to try to do it too much.
So, the other thing we did is we worked
with actually some great faculty and
others around the university, and we
created AI guidelines for communicators.
And these are now publicly available,
and they're just some basic common sense
things that try to address the fact of
attribution. If you're going to use AI,
don't like tell people you've used AI in
some process in this. Two is, you know,
understand the hallucinations are real,
so make sure you have backed up in terms
of fact-checking anything that you have
out there. And I think that's got to be
those two things have to go hand in
hand. Explore in moderation, see how it
can help you. And on the other side,
be careful and make sure you know where
the red lines are.
>> Thank you for summarizing that for us.
The the
the key takeaway I I have from what you
said is to what end?
To what end? You know, just because it's
there doesn't mean you need to use it,
doesn't mean you need to use it in a
specific way. I like that.
And and I think all of our colleagues
across the university who are so
instrumental in advancing AI would be
very pleased with your answer. So that
that's great, too.
Well, Farnaz, I knew this would be a
great conversation. We always have great
conversations when we grab coffee.
I'd like to end by asking you three
questions. One I'm going to create just
for you and two I've been asking
everybody for a long time.
We started our talk today highlighting
listening reflection.
I'd love for you to share a little bit
of advice on how you try to listen well
and any advice or guidance you give
others to improve listening skills.
>> I'm going to share story.
>> Great.
>> I [snorts] had a lot of great
experiences when I worked as a US
diplomat overseas. I was incredibly
privileged to do so.
And one of them was to meet some really
phenomenal people.
And when I was serving in Italy, I had
the chance to meet Bill Clinton.
And one of the great things about that
people will talk about Bill Clinton all
the time is that he is a great
communicator, but one of the reasons
that I thought and I saw it firsthand
was when I got to meet him
is
he makes you feel as if there is no one
else except you. Like he is truly
listening to you. And I met him in a
public forum in Florence with a thousand
people around us. But in that 20
seconds, I felt like I was the only
person. There was a real connection
there. So I think
none of us can be Bill Clinton, not all
of us can be Bill Clinton, but I felt
very much like
that taught me something. If your
attention is fully on someone, you're
not multitasking, you're not looking
over to the right, you're not doing
something else, but you actually look
like you're listening to someone, that
can go a long way.
That one very short interaction taught
me a lot years ago.
>> Yeah, paying attention and then having
the intention to really connect makes a
big difference. And regardless of what
you think of his politics, you know, he
he is very well known for that ability
to connect and to listen.
Uh thank you.
Question two,
who is a communicator that you admire
and why?
>> See, I thought that question might come
cuz I'm a long-time listener
>> Oh well, good. Thank you. Thank you.
>> And I'm going to be a little contrarian
there. I don't have one and I'll tell
you why.
>> Okay.
>> I think one of the things that as we've
talked about here,
communications has so many different
facets, right? You got to be a good
listener, you got to be able to be
clear, you got to be passionate about
your topic.
Different people have different
strengths in that. And it's hard for me
to think about one person who has all of
that, right? So, we just talked about
Bill Clinton and his ability to listen
and connect. If you look at someone,
let's say like an Oprah Winfrey, she's
fabulous at warmth.
>> Yeah.
>> And that is a really important part of
connection.
I spent many years doing
technical or science communications and
I'm a little bit of a nerd and a geek
that way, too, and I I'm passionate
about it. But when I look at somebody
like a Neil deGrasse Tyson or a Bill
Nye, their ability to simplify
is their strength. So, it feels to me
like you can take little pieces and
parts of everybody out there, like the
things that really matter to you and
say,
I want a little bit of this and a little
bit of that and a little bit of that. No
one person has that. I love a little
piece of all of them.
>> So, I will accept your heresy
because what you just shared in your
response is the purpose of this
question. It's really to look behind
what makes for good communicators and
you did a nice job of delineating it.
But I'm going to give you an opportunity
in our final question to give three
key ingredients for a successful
communication recipe. What are the the
most essential from your perspective?
>> Well, thank you for asking in threes.
>> Yes.
>> The three things that I think are
very much a reflection of some of the
things we've already talked about,
right? One is know your goal and your
audience. You got to know what you're
trying to communicate and who you're
trying to communicate to. Two, we just
finished talking about it, listening.
Are you a good listener? Do you do
active listening? Have you spent your
time actually thinking about what the
other person has said as opposed to
trying to be the one to to like think
ahead to what you're going to say.
On the third point, I'm going to diverge
a little bit. I'm going to say if you're
an individual, you're doing it in your
in your as a person versus as someone
representing an organization.
As a person,
I think people hear this, but they do
not always appreciate just how much
nonverbal communication matters, right?
So, how much your eye contact, your
smile, your body language, your gestures
make a difference. And so, be thoughtful
and be intentional about that.
In an organization, if you're
representing an organization for good
communications,
I had a great boss once who said,
"Farnoosh, a big part of your job is to
educate your bosses.
You think people know the same things
you do.
They don't know the same things you do.
So, effective communication is to make
sure that those who are decision makers
around you
are educated. They know what you know,
and that will lead to good
communications outcomes for an
organization.
>> Wow. Okay, lots there. So, so
goal-based, focusing on your audience,
listening, reflecting, absolutely key.
We've heard some of that before. The the
the importance of nonverbals. It's not
just the message, but how the message
comes across. And then, your job uh is
to make sure that those you're speaking
to, be they your bosses, your peers,
have the information they need to be
successful. So, the the goal of
communication is to educate, which
certainly doesn't surprise me given the
role that you have as head of comms at a
university. Fran, this was fantastic.
Lots of key takeaways from lots of
different areas of communication, from
how we can be better ourselves, how we
can better our organizations, how we can
handle crises, how we can deal with AI.
Thank you so much for your insight, and
thanks for joining.
>> Thank you for having me. That was a lot
of fun, Matt.
>> [music]